Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today I am going to explain the American post-apocalyptic
action film called “After Earth.”
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
The premise of the movie is set far in the
future when the earth has become uninhabitable.
Humans have to find another planet to settle
upon.
That is when the organization called the United
Ranger Corps is founded.
The United Ranger Corps is a global military
effort in the evacuation of the earth.
The rangers lead the settlement of mankind's
new home called Nova Prime.
The exodus ends when humanity settles on a
new pristine planet they call Nova Prime.
The only problem is that the planet already
has beings living on it.
The natives of Nova prime release monstrous
creatures called the ursas to get rid of the
human settlers.
The ursas are technically blind but they can
detect humans by sensing the pheromones that
the human brain releases when they are scared.
The creatures can literally smell fear in
humans and attack.
Because of them, humankind is again in danger
of extinction.
One thousand years later, the rangers who
had helped humans to evacuate the earth find
a way to defeat the ursas.
The prime commander Cypher Raige creates a
technique called ghosting where he can fearlessly
battle with the ursas making himself practically
invisible to them.
Using this technique, the rangers defeat the
ursas and live on Nova Prime peacefully.
The scene cuts to some teenagers training
to become rangers in the human settlement
of prime nova.
One of the ambitious teens is commander Cypher’s
son Kitai.
Kitai’s elder sister Senshi was killed while
trying to save him from an ursa so he trains
hard every day to become a ranger and fight
them.
On the evaluation day, the evaluator, Commander
tells Kitai that his test scores are impressive
but his field activity is average.
Hence, he is not selected as a ranger.
Kitai retaliates but Commander dismisses the
conversation.
In the following scene, we see the prime commander
Cypher finally arrive home after his expedition
to another planet.
He meets his wife Faia and greets her.
At night the family is having dinner when
Cypher asks Kitai about his training.
Kitai replies he hasn’t been selected and
Cypher simply asks him to try harder.
Kitai rudely gets up from the table making
Cypher yell at him to sit back down.
After dinner, Cypher tells Faia that he is
leaving for his last voyage to Iphitos to
train some rangers.
He plans to retire after the trip.
Faia asks him to take Kitai with him so he
could learn how to be a ranger.
She vaguely reveals that Kitai blames himself
for his elder sister Senshi’s death.
The following day, Cypher and Kitai prepare
to leave for the expedition.
Before they leave, Cypher is approached by
a ranger who has lost one of his legs in battle.
The ranger thanks Cypher for saving his life
and gets on his foot to salute him.
Kitai watches the commotion in fascination,
admiring how the other rangers respect his
father.
The rangers are also lifting a captured ursa
in their ship to use in training.
Everyone boards the spaceship and it finally
takes off.
Halfway in their trip, Cypher asks Kitai to
strap in and take a rest like the others.
But because of the uncomfortable seat, he
doesn’t fall asleep.
So, goes to a restricted area where the ursa
is kept.
He is then stopped by a ranger who makes fun
of him for being intrusive.
A group of rangers allows him to go near the
restrained ursa to see if he is fearless like
his father.
But the ursa smells Kitai’s fear and growls.
Just then, Cypher wakes up and checks the
gravitational force in the ship using a technology
fitted in his ring.
He notices something is off and orders the
rangers to secure all cargo.
Kitai goes back to his seat and straps himself
in.
Cypher then asks the pilot about the nearest
asteroid shower.
At first, the pilots do not detect one but
as time passes by they notice a heavy asteroid
shower coming their way.
It hits the ship making it shake aggressively
and causing some serious damage to it.
The rangers start to panic and the only one
strapped in is Kitai.
He hyperventilates, scared of what is about
to happen.
Cypher orders the pilots to travel to the
wormhole and they finally reach outside the
asteroid shower.
However, the ship is heavily damaged and cannot
go on for a long time, so they will have to
land on the nearest planet suitable for humans.
While searching for such a planet, the pilot
comes across the earth.
Cypher is skeptical about landing on their
old home because the earth has become a class-1
quarantined planet after humans’ departure
but has no other way out.
As the ship falls on the earth’s surface
at an uncontrollable speed, Cypher approaches
his son and calms him down.
Kitai gets visions of the time they were attacked
by an ursa and his sister Senshi was killed.
Just then, the ship starts to break causing
everyone around Kitai to fall off it.
At last, Kitai falls unconscious and crashlands
on the surface of the earth.
Humans have returned to earth after a thousand
years.
After a while, he wakes up and looks around
to find the dead bodies of fellow rangers.
He also sees his father lying limp on the
ground and hugs him.
To Kitai’s surprise, Cypher gains consciousness
and greets him.
But both of his legs are severely injured
making it impossible for him to stand up.
Cypher asks him how many people survived,
only to find out that everyone except for
them is dead.
Moreover, the rear part of the ship is absent
meaning that the captured ursa has landed
somewhere else.
Cypher believes that the creature might be
dead from the impact but still asks Kitai
to be careful.
Cypher makes Kitai get an emergency beacon
that can be used to send signals to a rescue
group in prime nova.
But they are disappointed to see that the
beacon is fully damaged.
Then, Kitai takes Cypher to the control panel
which is still working.
From there, Cypher finds out the location
of the second beacon that is in the tail section
of the ship.
A hologram shows that the second beacon has
landed a hundred kilometers away from their
current location.
Without the beacon, they will never be able
to get back home, so they will have to retrieve
it.
But since Cypher is not in a condition to
walk, Kitai will have to do it himself.
Cypher warns him about the creatures of the
earth who have evolved to kill humans in the
past thousand years.
The journey will not be easy for Kitai but
Cypher will be watching him and his trails
from the control panel at all times.
Cypher gives Kitai his weapon, a wrist communicator,
and six capsules of a fluid that enhances
the oxygen intake so he can breathe in Earth's
low-oxygen atmosphere.
He asks Kitai to take the capsules in regular
intervals and sets him off for his journey.
Starting his journey, Kitai climbs a sloppy
hill and reaches the top.
There, he is fascinated to see several lives
on the earth.
The earth now has violent thermal shifts because
of which the nights are too cold to handle.
Hence, Cypher advises Kitai to reach the “hot
spots” caused by the geothermal energy every
night to keep himself warm.
After that, Cypher checks the condition of
his legs and sees that they are severely damaged.
He takes a painkiller for the moment which
makes him go hazy.
By midday, Kitai reaches a forest when Cypher
notices a creature approaching him from the
monitor.
He informs Kitai of the creature and asks
him to stay put.
The animal turns out to be an evolved violent
monkey.
Kitai gets scared and throws a rock at the
animal, attracting a group of monkeys who
chase him.
A worried Cypher gives him the directions
as Kitai runs for his life.
The monkeys leave him after he jumps into
a river.
Kitai finally stops running and finds a poisonous
leech stuck to him.
He hurriedly removes the parasite but the
creature has already left its venom in his
body.
Kitai starts to lose his vision and his body
stops moving.
Cypher orders him to get an antidote from
his medical kit.
Kitai injects the dose and falls unconscious
right after.
After a while, Cypher wakes Kitai up saying
that the temperature is dropping rapidly as
night approaches.
He will have to get to a hot spot quickly
if he doesn’t want to freeze to death.
Kitai wakes up, completely healed from the
leach’s poison, and makes his way forward.
Meanwhile, Cypher performs a make-do surgery
on his legs to make them better but he knows
that he doesn’t have much time left.
At that moment, he reminisces about the time
he wished his daughter a happy birthday before
her death.
A while later, Kitai finally arrives at the
first hotspot.
He checks his equipment for the day and sees
that two capsules of liquid that enhance his
oxygen level are destroyed.
This means that he will have to reach his
destination sooner.
Knowing that Cypher will ask him to return
if he finds out about the broken vials, Kitai
lies saying everything is intact.
At night, Kitai asks Cypher how he discovered
the ghosting technique for the first time.
Cypher tells him that he was going on a run
when an ursa appeared right in front of him.
A scared Cypher froze and the ursa shot its
pincer right through Cypher’s shoulder making
the both of them fall into a river off the
cliff.
At the bottom of the river, the ursa remained
on top of Cypher trying to drown him.
At that moment, Cypher accepted his death
and wasn’t scared anymore.
Because of this, the ursa couldn’t see him
and he was able to kill it.
Kitai falls asleep listening to the story.
The following day, he continues his journey.
Halfway through the day, Cypher starts to
notice hints of the presence of ursa in the
area.
Kitai reaches a tall waterfall which he will
have to cross to reach the destination.
Cypher asks him to check his supplies and
is disappointed to see that he has only two
vials of liquid oxygen left.
An embarrassed Kitai says he can make it to
the tail with just two but Cypher asks him
to abort the mission.
Right then, Kitai gets a flashback of the
day his sister Senshi died.
An ursa had attacked their home and like always,
Cypher was on a mission somewhere else.
To save her brother’s life, Senshi had kept
him inside a glass sphere from where the ursa
couldn’t smell his fear.
That day, Kitai witnessed his sister getting
killed in front of him and to this date, he
blames himself for it.
Back in the present, Kitai argues with Cypher
claiming that he is not a coward.
Cypher tries to calm him but in the moment
of rage, Kitai jumps off the cliff.
He uses his suit to guide the direction of
his fall.
Just when he thinks that he can make it to
the bottom, a large bird attacks him and breaks
his communicator.
Now, Cypher has no way to contact Kitai.
A while later, Kitai wakes up in the bird’s
nest surrounded by its chicks.
Before he can get out, all of them are attacked
by a group of panthers.
The mother bird fights the one on the top
of the nest while Kitai fights a panther inside
it.
By the end of the fight, all of the bird’s
chicks are dead.
As it tries to revive them in frustration,
Kitai runs away from the place.
Meanwhile, Cypher tries to look for Kitai
through his satellite monitors but instead
finds two rangers impaled to a tree.
The system detects the presence of an ursa
in the area.
Unknown to this, Kitai takes rest in a cave
for the night.
Without his father navigating the way, he
has to rely on his memory to reach the tail
of the ship.
He draws a map on the wall and decides to
follow it.
The next morning, he continues the journey
but is troubled by the same bird following
him everywhere.
At midday, he has a hard time breathing so
he takes his last vial of oxygen.
Then, to reach the tail sooner, he builds
a raft from logs and continues his journey.
After some time, Kitai falls asleep and dreams
of his sister telling him he is close to the
destination.
He wakes up right before the temperature fluctuation
starts and goes around looking for a hotspot.
However, without Cypher’s help, he is unable
to find one.
The temperature drops extremely low and everything
around him freezes.
Soon, Kitai drops unconscious on the ground
and we see something drag him to a warm safe
corner.
Kitai wakes up the following morning to see
that the bird has saved his life.
It had covered him with leaves and twigs,
treating him as his chicks.
Kitai thanks the bird but notices it is already
dead.
However, with no time to waste, he moves forward
and finally finds the tail of the ship.
He finds a vial of liquid oxygen and quickly
takes it which rejuvenates him to some extent.
Then, he sees that the ursa is missing from
where it is supposed to be.
Kitai gets the beacon and contacts Cypher
using the panel in the tail.
Cypher, who is only somewhat conscious, is
delighted to see his son alive.
However, Kitai cannot hear him because of
some technical issue.
Kitai then tries using the beacon but it doesn’t
work due to atmospheric interference.
Cypher asks him to try from a different location
but since Kitai cannot hear him, he only gets
more frustrated.
But after a while, Kitai sees a volcano nearby
and decides to try using the beacon from the
top of it.
However, trouble soon follows when the lost
ursa tracks Kitai and senses his fear.
Cypher sees this from the monitor and is worried
for him.
Kitai, on the other hand, finds out that the
creature is following him and starts to run.
The ursa attacks Kitai but he manages to save
himself after jumping into a waterbody and
going up the mountain.
Just then, the temperature starts to lower
which freezes Kitai, making him fall to the
ground.
At the same time, Cypher also falls unconscious
because of his injuries.
The ursa approaches Kitai as he thinks of
his father’s words.
He remembers that fear is not real and it’s
all only in his head.
Just then, the creature walks right past Kitai,
unable to detect him.
He has removed fear from his mind and is now
able to ghost the creature.
Using his newfound courage, Kitai kills the
creature easily.
He then uses the beacon to send signals to
their rescue team.
In the next scene, Kitai is on a rescue ship.
He walks forwards as everyone watches him
in appreciation.
Cypher lies on a bed being treated for his
injuries.
After seeing his son, he makes the rangers
stand him up and salutes Kitai in a true ranger
fashion.
The movie ends after the father and the son
hug and the ship takes off for nova prime.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thanks for watching.